la imagen es poco habitual la explanada
de las mezquitas transformada en un
campo de batalla tras el gran rezo del
viernes el último del ramadán los
palestinos decidieron quedarse a
protestar la policía israelí disparó
balas de goma gases lacrimógenos y
granadas aturdidoras para desalojar a
los manifestantes los más decididos se
enfrentaron a los oficiales tirando
piedras y botellas e incluso cuerpo a
cuerpo
quieren permitir que extremistas y
colonos se entren a la mezquita de
al-aqsa todo lo que está sucediendo
tiene como objetivo perseguir a la gente
y expulsarla y tratar de vaciar
completamente jerusalén durante varios
días después de la interrupción del
ayuno del ramadán el barrio de sheikh
jarrah en jerusalén ha sido escenario de
enfrentamientos
aquí varias familias palestinas se
enfrentan a la amenaza de desalojo en
beneficio de los colonos judíos
el plan es ocupar toda jerusalén y
convertirla en una ciudad judía étnica y
en desarrollo que carezca de presencia
árabe eso les permitiría ocupar la
capital palestina y obtener todas las
casas
hamas el movimiento islamista que
controla la franja de gaza llamó a los
palestinos a permanecer en la explanada
hasta el final del mes sagrado el
próximo jueves washington aliado
histórico de israel expresó su
preocupación por los desalojos de
familias palestinas a los que la onu ha
calificado de crímenes de guerra la
corte suprema israelí decidiría el
próximo lunes sobre la posible expulsión
de cuatro familias palestinas